1 km de laïcité inauguré à guillancour
le chemin pédestre jusqu'alors sans
appellation a profité de la journée
nationale de la laïcité pour se faire un
nom le 9 décembre c'est la date
anniversaire de la de la loi sur la
séparation des Églises et de l'État mais
c'est aussi la date qui a été choisie
par le Sénat et le texte de loi va
maintenant aller à l'Assemblée pour
faire de cette date le 9 décembre la
journée nationale de la laïcité un
véritable symbole pour la ville de
guillancour qui dispose déjà d'un
rond-point des
d'une rue de la Liberté et d'une place
de la fraternité chemin parce que vous
savez la laïcité c'est une conquête ce
sont bien sûr des valeurs celle de de
liberté de conscience et celle de vivre
ensemble mais c'est aussi une conquête
et le chemin représente bien cette image
de conquête le chemin de la laïcité
permet de se balader entre le quartier
des garenes et celui des sa tout près
des bâtiments universitaires vauan et
d'alambert